I just want you to know
I'm not taking this trip to this again
reunited and it's sweeter than any
amount of watermelon sugar
watermelon sugar
on Tuesday Harry Styles reunited with
his all-time Mega fan and the internet's
beloved Grandma Rina lafonazay this
every Ontario resident met the global
Superstar when she was named his biggest
fan and presented him with a Grammy
award for album of the year and every
say the moment was truly golden
golden
golden the pair reunited at Harry's
concert in Coventry England on Monday
night taking two Instagram Arena shared
photos of herself alongside her daughter
and granddaughter next to the one and
only Harry Styles writing now imagine my
shock and joy when I was invited
backstage to meet our Harry and have him
walk in towards me singing the song
reunited and It Feels So Good by Peaches
and Herb while giving me a hug
nice to see you and if that wasn't
perfect enough she added he is the most
caring humble and down-to-earth person
in such a great sense of humor his smile
and joy de Viva lit up the room how
adorable they say never meet your Heroes
but if your hero is Harry Style then I
think it's safe to say you should
probably meet him now we need to Canada
caught up with Rina post Grammys she
revealed just how much she had to
contain her excitement I couldn't
believe it I just I hugged him as hard
as he hugged me I just oh I just could
not believe that he was there and I kept
saying I just I gotta keep it together I
gotta keep it together like my knees
were getting weaker by the minute